justo un día antes del aniversario del
primer confinamiento por ccoo y 19 en
francia llegaron difíciles noticias para
los residentes de la región de parís un
tercer cierre está oficialmente sobre la
mesa y estamos en una situación crítica
y preocupante
que me parece que de hecho es hora de
considerar nuevas medidas para la gran
región de parís juego fácil los
comentarios del primer ministro se
produjeron pocas horas después de que
confirmara que francia había entrado en
una tercera ola de la pandemia
caracterizada en gran parte por un
aumento de variantes más contagiosos y
mortales pero este sombrío panorama no
se detiene ahí con 419 casos por cada
100.000 residentes por semana la región
de parís también ha cruzado el umbral de
la tasa de infección de 400 que había
fijado el primer ministro hace unos días
el aumento de las infecciones ha llevado
a las instalaciones de salud de la
región al borde del colapso las unidades
de cuidados intensivos de la capital y
sus alrededores están casi repletas lo
que obliga al estado
a trasladar a los pacientes a otros
hospitales del país hay tantos pacientes
en rehabilitación hoy como en el pico de
la segunda ola estamos en una fase de
aceleración ha llegado el momento de
poner en marcha más medidas
para que no acabemos diciendo que no a
los pacientes que necesitan tratamiento
para cáncer o cuidados cardiovasculares
ya se han implementado cierres de fin de
semana en dunkerque niza y el paso de
khaled el presidente manuel macro señaló
que quería evitar el confinamiento a
toda costa pero a medida que parís se
enfrenta a un aumento en los casos la
perspectiva de un cierre regional parece
cada vez más probable